bonsoir wendy renard merci beaucoup
d'avoir choisi martinique la première
pour la sortie de votre autobiographie
alors généralement c'est un exercice
qu'on fait un peu en fin de carrière
mais rassurez nous vous n'avez pas
l'intention de raccrocher les crampons
poutine n'ont pas du tout non je pense à
une question aussi de timing
après c'est des propositions qui ont été
faites et tout le bon moment
je tirais n'y a pas de bons moments en
fait à partir du moment où
on a des choses à exprimer on vous fait
comprendre que votre parcours peu à
servir à beaucoup de jeunes bas il faut
pas hésiter une seconde et même s'ils
avaient beaucoup de discussions parce
que je suis pas trop quelqu'un qui aime
s'éterniser sur sur sa vie d'une manière
générale donc après à partir du moment
que ça touche un peu les jeunes je suis
partant c'était un peu pour donner
l'exemple en quelque sorte de très
impliquée à auprès des jeunes et des
jeunes footballeurs et footballeuses
aussi qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
pouvez
qu'est ce que vous faites pour pour eux
pour nous pour nos footballeurs nos
jeunes footballeurs et ses bas tout
simplement déjà de par ce que je fais au
quotidien
je pense que naturellement bas je sais
que je suis parti très jeune je pense
que c'est un exemple aussi à suez sur
tous deux qu'ils puissent se dire que
tout est possible en fait qu' il ya des
gens même des footballeurs avant moi qui
sont qui sont partis aujourd'hui je suis
parti en ado d'air moi qui sont encore
partie donc tout est possible à partir
du moment qu'on quoi et qu'on est
déterminé dans la vie a à faire beaucoup
de sacrifices et aussi travailler parce
qu'il ya son travail on n'arrive pas à
grand-chose tout est question de
détermination ou est ce que vous l'avez
trouvé cette cette gnac 7 ce mental bah
je viens d'une famille assez assez ce
parti je pense depuis tout petit je le
dis souvent mes amis je frappais dans
déjà dans le ventre de ma mère après
comme on dit dans le reportage les
chiens ne font pas des chats voilà je
pense que je tiens aussi à beaucoup de
ma famille de ma mère et de mon papa est
aussi de mes soeurs parce que comme
maman n'était pas là c'était les soeurs
qui prenait le relais donc
donc après ccc de par l'éducation que
vos parents vous ont donné que vous
brandissez et vous devenez aussi matures
après vous prenez des décisions dès fois
bonne des fois pas bonne mais dans la
vie tout tout vous saurez tout vous
permettre de m'en dire votre étoile
c'est votre papa justement votre exemple
assez plus que mon exemple c'est mon
père c'est un être cher que j'aurais
aimé qu'il soit là mais je pense que de
là où il doit être fier de sa fille
comme des autres pour moi voilà ça fait
partie de ma vie c'est un moment
douloureux mais à
aujourd'hui voilà il est là et c'est mon
et toi donc c'est un titre que ma mère
elle a choisi donc je suis cependant
pour lui rendre hommage et c c'est ce
qui a été le plus le plus difficile
finalement de mettre à plat des choses
plus personnelles peut-être que votre
carrière sportive c'est ça ouais parce
que parler de son enfance des choses un
peu que les gens ne sont pas forcément
ben non pas aussi besoin de savoir on va
dire c'est ça qui est un peu plus
difficile on entre un peu dans ton en
ton intimité
après c'est ça aussi qui fait à celle
que je suis aujourd'hui donc pour moi je
pense que c'est important de dire de
choisir ses les chapitres mais de dire
quand même pas mal pas mal de choses
dans mon enfant et vous l'avez dit
chappaqua fait chaque d'ailleurs il ya
beaucoup d' expression créole qui sont
utilisés dans le livre c'est une langue
que vous devez avoir toujours en tête
utiliser même quand vous êtes très loin
finalement du pays bacchus et c'est même
pas un devoir en fait c'est naturel ce
sont mes racines
et comme je dis souvent je suis né ici
j'ai frappé mes premiers ballons au
prêcheur
donc non je n'oublie pas de je viens
c'est un c pour moi c'est un créé c'est
naturel et c'est pas du tout hein
un run ya un jeu
je suis fier d'être anti âge du fer de
martiniquaise et j'essaye tout au long
de mon parcours de justin gagner pour
terminer à tous les jeunes footballeurs
et footballeuses qui vous qui vous
regardent ce soir ben croyant vous soyez
déterminer sur tout ça se passe à
l'intérieur c'est pas maman c'est papa
qui doit vous dire vous devez faire ça
ou devait faire six croyez juste en vous
et dans la vie tout est possible il faut
juste travailler être déterminé et puis
encore encore une fois avoir la foi et
est avancé wendy renard mon étoile
publié aux éditions talent sport
wendy bruno remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation